двійку українських винищувачів міг-29 на
Малій висоті виконують бойовий політ з
повним боєкомплектом за штурвалом пілоти
з позивним Джус він один з тих кого
називають привидами Києва попри
кількісну і якісну перевагу російської
авіації українські льотчики з перших
днів повномасштабної війни тримають
контроль над небом наш особливий склад
Як льотний так і так іноземний
адаптувалися до
умов цієї війни і
викрадають з цієї техніки просто
не 100% мабуть 300 відсотків того що з
нею можна витиснути і як в тактичному
плані так і в технічному плані оскільки
Ну деякі літаки просто цілодобові
літають практично з такою високою
інтенсивністю відповідно це впливає і на
їх технічне обслуговування тобто люди
цього допомогу працюють на цих літаках і
підтримують їхню можливість винищувачі
міг-29 і су-27 є основними бойовими
літаками українських повітряних сил
також застосовуються штурмовики су-25 і
бомбардувальники су-24 міг-29 на яких
літає зокрема і Джус у середньому
1989-91-го років виробництва такі машини
виконують бойові завдання Але часто за
межами своїх технічних можливостей
наприклад ті самі шахіди у нас
наш бортовий радар створений 40 років
назад Він не був розрахований на цілі
такого розміру і таких швидкостей коли
наші льотчики все ж таки вишукують і
знаходяться шахіди і все ж таки успішно
вражають Тобто це вже є таким можна
сказати тактичним чудом оскільки
ну сказати гарантовано що це от заводом
закладено і ти просто маєш зробити по
інструкції все вийде на жаль так воно не
працює
Зовні не з'явилося жодного
нудьки модернізації а пілоти отримали
більше досвіду Утім українські льотчики
досі працюють на Радянській техніці а
спадок СРСР був чималий у музеї важкої
бомбардувальної авіації у Полтаві його
можна побачити На власні очі за різними
підрахунками і тільки з відкритих джерел
тому що ну важко точно встановити
кількість але безумовно ця кількість
була більш ніж одна тисяча бойових
літаків ще плюс 500 додати гелікоптерів
різного призначення і таке інше от тобто
ну Україна тоді
зважаючи на її невеличку територію так з
1600 км заходу на схід отримали
достатньо величезний такий авіапотенціал
за часів Радянського Союзу саме в
Україні базувалася стратегічна авіація
тому на момент розпаду СРСР Україна
поступалася за кількістю і потенціалом
стратегічної авіації лише сполученим
штатам і могла на рівних змагатися з
Росією і Китаєм нині такі літаки можна
побачити хіба що у музеї
далеко сьогодні тут 22м3 тут 95 МС носії
крилатих і ядерних ракет в Україні це
унікальні музейні експонати а в Росії
зброя саме з 122 РФ запускає ракети х-22
такі ракети поцілили по житловому
будинку в Дніпрі у січні цьогоріч і по
торговому центрі в Кременчуці влітку
надзвуковий туз 160 із розмахом крил 55
метрів теж викликає неоднозначні
відчуття Колись він вважався найбільшим
і найпотужнішим бомбардувальником
планети а від пілотів отримав прізвисько
Білий лебідь в Україні один із чотирьох
полків нашої дивізії 13-ї важкої дивізії
в Прилуках там було 19 літаків таких
зосереджено відповідно ну це за
відкритими джерелами
і саме в Прилуках вони і тестувалися
виходили на надзвуковий режим запускали
крилаті ракети і таке інше на жаль це
літак на сьогодні
До сих пір досить смерть запускаючи
відповідно свої ракети по українським
містам незалежно Україна проголосила
себе мирною і без'ядерною державою тож
наприклад із 19-ти ту-160-х які
базувалися в незалежній Україні 10
розпиляли на металобрухт ще 8 передали
Росії замість боргів за газ один у 2000
році власним ходом перелетів з Прилук до
Полтави на вічно стоянку тут 95-х було
утилізовано тут я вам точно не скажу але
три таких літаки було передано
Російській Федерації знову От і вони є
носіями крилатих ракет Отже їм були
також передані і 575 крилатих ракет
серії х-55 відповідно які вони можуть
нести на такому спеціальному
[музика]
барабанні револьверного типу Чи була
можливість в України зберегти
стратегічні ракетоносці бомбардувальники
знадобилися б вони нині співробітник
музею Віктор мирошник хоч і віддає
належне творінню радянських
конструкторів у цьому не певен ці літаки
стратегічні бомбардувальники вони
збиралися і збираються на казанському
авіаційному заводі відповідно і як ми
всі знаємо з відкритих джерел це Відомо
що в Радянському Союзі на території
України не було якихось важливих
стратегічних Скажімо так заводів які
виробляли б ці стратегічні бомбардування
які відповідно все це було на території
Російської Федерації це Скажімо так Чи
виникає питання чи могли б ми їх
підтримувати в бойовому стані це ж не
машина якась це ж не автомобіль Пілот
Just так само говорить що значення
видатки на утримання стратегічної
авіації і підготовку льотчиків були б не
виправданими як ми їх застосували
так само як і вони виконували би пуски
ракетка 22 так само влучаючи куди попало
так само
тероризуючи їхні міста і чи наскільки
легше ставив бійцям десь під бахмутом
ні на скільки оскільки все одно
лишається величезна перевага в артилерії
величезна перевага в тактичній авіації в
армійській авіації в танках бойових
машинах піхоти на думку льотчика
протягом останніх 20 років в Україні
варто було б зосередитися на
модернізації тактичної авіації тих самих
міг-29 Утім нині каже Джус це вже робити
запізно адже озброєння радянських
літаків уже не відповідає вимогам
сучасної війни а запчастин замало на
деякі політиків в Європі І взагалі
західних країнах немає запчастин в
принципі
оскільки вони їх не використовували вони
на них ніколи не озброєнні не стояли і
Певний момент ці запчастини закінчуються
плюс питання в наявності озброєння
Авіаційна озброєння саме під цілі такі
Так зараз воно ще поки що є але так чи
інакше воно ви складається щодня І ці
запаси поповнювати немає звідки деякі
типи озброєння просто їх більше нема
ніде звісно крім нашого ворога наразі
захід на
Західна платформа в західні літаки це
єдиний шлях
виправлення тих наших помилок помилок
минулого історичних помилок
через які ми недостатньо були
підготовлені в авіаційному плані до цієї
війни і ці помилки скажемо в них були
викликані не тим що хтось Просто не
хотів А знову ж таки
глобальним станом економіки економіки
держави і ще багатьма багатьма факторами
зокрема зокрема і впливом самої Росії
американський багатоцільові винищувачі
f16 в українських повітряних силах
називають оптимальною платформою за
словами пілота джуса ці літаки зможуть
кардинально змінити від бойових дій а
також допоможуть остаточно залишити
радянський спадок для музеїв